[Music]
jared is in irvine california hi jared
welcome to the ramsey show
hey mr randy how's it going better than
i deserve sir what's up in your world
hey so i was just calling with a
question for you
um i'm looking to get some guidance as
to whether or not
i should sell my house
and move up or if i should stay where
i'm at
with the smaller space i'll give you a
little background real quick
we're in a two-bedroom condo right now
and we have two
small children so the boys are sharing a
room
and we're gonna be trying for a third
here real soon so
that's why i'm having the debate of do i
sell in this awesome seller's market and
try to move up and maybe stretch our
budget a little thin or do i just suck
it up and
try to cram three kids in a two-bedroom
condo yeah
are you out of debt except the condo
uh yes we're in baby steps four five and
six good
okay when you make the move up are you
gonna do it on a 15-year fixed where the
payments no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay
uh yes that's the plan if you can do
that i don't have anything my
question too uh just trying to figure
out how much exactly i can afford
without
you know stretching too far 25 of your
take-home pay is a payment on a 15-year
fixed rate and if you do that you know
you're not going to be stretched too
thin
you're going to be okay the problem gets
in is because the let me tell you the
mortgage company
will approve you for almost twice that
much
almost twice that much to where as much
in other words i'll move you over to a
30 from a 15 and then they'll jam that
ratio all the way as high as they can
jam it up in the high 30s
up close to 40 of your take-home pay and
uh and then you're on a 30-year mortgage
and now you're owned by them
which is the goal instead what we're our
goal is to get you into that mortgage
and get you into that house and get you
back out of that mortgage
and that's why we do a 15-year fix let's
get it paid off in 10 then
and have a game plan to get at it but it
does sound like you need to move dude
you've got kids coming out everywhere
it's just like
you got you got a whole stack of them
there man the two boys in the room you
can manage that
the third one changes that whole
equation yeah yeah and it's it's
obviously getting tight in there but um
yeah you just can't use the
old i'm in california excuse because you
know the
math still works in california
in spite of what some of the politicians
say math still works in california
so it's still what has to happen there